You know how sometimes you think
you really get someone or or an
idea, but then you dig a bit
deeper and find something else
entirely underneath?
Maybe something a bit
unsettling?
Yeah, that happens a lot,
doesn't it?
It's like we get these polished
versions of people or history.
Exactly.
Historical figures, cultural
movements, even spiritual icons,
they're presented in a certain
way and well, we tend to just
accept it, right?
But what if that image, the one
we all know, is actually
constructed carefully put
together, maybe even
deliberately shaped to, I don't
know, take away its original
punch?
That's it's right at the heart
of what we're digging into
today.
We're looking at how these big
societal power structures, what
academics call hegemony, use
this really subtle strategy.
It's a way to neutralize figures
and ideas that were once, well,
dangerous.
Revolutionary.
We're calling this process
deburring.
Deburring.
OK.
Like taking burrs off metal,
smoothing it down.
Precisely, in manufacturing you
remove the sharp bits, the rough
spots make it smooth, safe Here
deburring is about sanding down
the sharp edges of a radical
person or a challenging idea.
Polishing it up, maybe
rebranding.
It exactly rebranding it so it's
safe for everyone, safe for mass
consumption.
So you take someone who
genuinely scared the
establishment, who wanted to
flip things upside down, right?
And you turn them into
something, well, harmless, maybe
even respected, but without that
original fire, the.
Power's gone.
It's a kind of control through
transformation, OK.
So our mission today for you
listening is really to get a
handle on this process, right?
Yeah, exactly.
This isn't just history lessons.
It's about giving you a lens, a
way to see how our understanding
of, well, everything, culture,
politics, even spirituality,
gets shaped subtly but
constantly.
It's happening all around us and
we've been looking at some
really fascinating sources for
this analysis critiques.
Yeah, things that explore how
these revolutionary leaders
somehow end up as like.
Mascots.
Or how really sharp ideas get
Sort of watered down until
they're safe for everyone.
We.
Want to unpack how it happens,
what it looks like and you know
what it really means for us
trying to understand the world?
OK, so let's really get into
this deburring radicals idea.
What the sources keep pointing
out is that hegemony, this sort
of network of power and shared
beliefs.
It doesn't just, you know, crush
its enemies head on all the
time.
And sometimes it does,
obviously.
Right, but often the more
effective way, maybe the
sneakier way, is transformation.
That's the key thing.
It's not always suppression,
which can backfire, create
martyrs, you know?
Instead, it's often about taking
that leader or that idea that
really poses a threat, something
that disrupts things.
Something scary to the status
quo.
Exactly.
And then suddenly, sometimes not
so subtly, turning it into
something harmless, maybe even
celebrating it like you said,
making it a national symbol.
But the sting is gone.
The sting is gone.
The original dangerous change
making power is stripped away.
It's neutralized by being well
domesticated, tamed.
And the ways they do this,
they're everywhere, aren't they?
It's kind of clever in a
disturbing way.
It really is like turning a real
firebrand, someone who scared
people into just a character in
a kids book.
Or a national holiday.
That sounds great, right?
But it often means simplifying
everything they stood for.
Yeah, or boiling down a whole
complex philosophy into just a
slogan.
Or a T-shirt.
That's the classic.
All right, the dangerous part,
the critique of power, the thing
that made them matter.
It just gets smoothed out,
sanded down until anyone can
handle it.
And the result isn't that the
idea vanishes.
Sometimes it becomes even more
famous.
But it's neutralized.
It is.
It loses its power to actually
inspire fundamental change or to
be a real threat.
It's still there, but it's
defamed.
It's like a museum piece.
Polished up, but the original
uncomfortable bits are gone.
Exactly.
So why is this way of doing
things, this sort of gentle
control?
Why is it so effective compared
to just, you know, cracking
down?
Well, I think part of it is it
looks benign.
It can even look like honoring
someone.
Right.
It's hard to argue against a
holiday or a statue.
Exactly.
It sort of absorbs the critique.
How can you criticize the
sanitized version without
looking, I don't know, negative
or unpatriotic?
That makes sense, and the
sources suggest why the system
might prefer this, not just
crushing things.
Yeah, a couple of reasons seem
to come up. 1 Is that the
original idea?
Or the person might just be too
powerful to resonate with people
to actually erase?
Trying to crush it might just
make it stronger, OK.
And 2nd, if you can't erase it,
maybe you can coopt it.
You can kind of absorb it and
use it.
Use it for profit or just to
make the system seem OK.
Both potentially put it in
merchandise or use the sanitized
version to say, see, we value
these things too.
It sort of uses the opponent's
own energy against.
Them like ideological judo or
something?
Yeah, something like that turns
a bomb into an ornament.
OK, let's make this concrete
case study #1 Martin Luther King
Junior.
I think for most people,
probably myself included, the
first image that pops up is the
I have a Dream King.
The famous speech.
Yeah, the profit of color
blindness.
Kids holding hands.
Unity.
He's on the holiday, taught in
schools.
He's a symbol of American
progress, right?
And that image while true in its
own way and important.
It is important.
It is, but the sources really
hammer this point.
It's radically incomplete.
It's a curated version.
It leaves out the much more
challenging King who emerged
later, sort of mid to late 60's.
The Dream.
Speech was 63.
So what happened after that?
What's the part that gets left
out?
Well, this is the erased MLK,
the one who was genuinely seen
as dangerous.
After the big legislative
victories like the Civil Rights
Act, Boarding Rights Act, his
focus really broadened.
Civil rights to.
To human rights and crucially,
economic justice.
He starts seeing capitalism
itself is deeply tied to racism,
poverty, war.
Wow, OK.
He became a really fierce
critic.
He wasn't just asking for a seat
at the table anymore.
He was questioning the whole
structure of the House.
He started talking about a
radical redistribution of
economic and political power.
That's yeah, that's definitely
not the version you usually hear
about.
Not at all.
And then there was his stance on
the Vietnam War.
Right, he spoke out very
strongly.
Uncompromisingly, that famous
speech at Riverside Church in
67?
He didn't pull any punches.
He called the United States the
greatest purveyor of violence in
the world today.
That must have caused a massive
backlash.
Huge, even from within the civil
rights movement.
He was stepping way outside the
accepted boundaries, directly
challenging US foreign policy,
linking it to poverty at home.
This wasn't just about harmony
anymore.
This is about confronting power.
And he wasn't just talking, he
started organizing the Poor
People's Campaign.
Yes, this was huge.
A multiracial army, he called
it, of the poor, black, white,
Latino, Native American to March
on Washington.
What were they demanding?
Not just rights, but concrete
economic change.
Guaranteed jobs, a living wage,
decent housing.
It was an economic Bill of
Rights, essentially a direct
challenge to the system, uniting
poor people across racial lines.
So this king, anti capitalist,
anti war, organizing the poor.
This king terrified the
establishment, the FBI, the
White House, the documents show
it.
They saw him as a genuine
revolutionary threat.
And he was spied on, slandered.
Constantly intense surveillance,
smear campaigns.
And then, of course, he was
assassinated in 68, right before
the Big March.
So how did that king get turned
into the safe holiday version we
mostly remember well?
That's the deburring, isn't it?
The holiday, the school lessons,
the public monuments They focus
almost exclusively on the dream
speech, the message of racial
harmony.
Which is important, but.
But it carefully avoids the
later, more radical king.
The king who challenged economic
structures, who condemned
militarism.
That part gets scrubbed out.
He's framed as someone who
helped America fulfill its
existing ideals, not someone who
fundamentally challenged them.
So he becomes safe,
inspirational, patriotic even.
Exactly made palatable and the
implication for us listening is
what do we lose when we only get
this sanitized version?
We lose the sense of what real
change looks like, how hard it
is.
I think so.
It makes us forget that progress
often comes from people who made
the powerful deeply
uncomfortable.
It teaches A subtle lesson that
change should be nice,
incremental, not disruptive.
And that's a distortion, really.
OK, so Malcolm X presents a
different angle on this right?
Because he wasn't sanitized
after death in the same way King
was.
He was actively demonized while
he was alive.
That's right.
It's a fascinating contrast.
While he was alive, the
mainstream narrative absolutely
painted him as the dangerous 1.
The Militant, the.
Counterpoint to King's non
violence.
Exactly.
Headlines screamed about hate,
separatism, he was seen as
violent, anti white, just
completely outside the bounds of
acceptable discourse, especially
early on with the Nation of
Islam.
And his rhetoric was powerful by
any means necessary, That phrase
alone.
It terrified white America, even
while it resonated with black
frustration.
He wasn't asking for acceptance.
He was demanding self respect,
self-defense, challenging the
very foundation of American
Society.
Unapologetic.
But then after he was killed in
65, something started to shift
in how he was remembered.
Yeah, subtle softening began, a
kind of post mortem deburring.
The sharpest edges, the strong
black nationalism, the really
biting critique of systemic
racism, the call for separation.
They start to get well-rounded
off a bit in the popular memory.
How so?
What did he become instead?
He started being remembered more
as a courageous leader who spoke
truth to power, which of course
he did.
But it's a specific framing.
It is.
It emphasizes his bravery, his
eloquence, his personal
evolution, especially after his
split with the Nation of Islam
and his Hajj.
These are important parts of his
story, but focusing on them can
sometimes downplay the core
confrontational nature of his
political thought throughout
much of his public life.
So the fire gets dimmed a
little.
You can say that the sharp edge
gets dulled just enough, and the
sources point out something
really telling relatively
quickly after his death, he
became safe enough that even
school textbooks could mention
him without fear.
Wow.
That's a huge shift from being
Public Enemy number.
One it is.
It means his message got
recontextualized.
He could be studied as history,
as an important voice, but maybe
without feeling his
revolutionary impulse as an
immediate call to action today.
So King was sanitized by erasing
his radicalism, turning him into
consensus.
Malcolm X was maybe reframed his
militancy downplayed, his truth
telling emphasized in a less
threatening way.
That seems to be the pattern,
yeah.
Different methods, same result,
neutralizing the threat.
And what does that tell us when
figures who were once seen as
completely beyond the pale are
eventually made safe for the
institutions they fought
against?
It suggests the system is
incredibly good at absorbing
things, at digesting descent.
It can take even the most fiery
opposition and eventually turn
it into something manageable,
something you can teach in
schools without causing too much
trouble.
It's a lesson in how history
gets written or rewritten to fit
the needs of the present and.
Speaking of absorption, maybe
the most visually obvious
example is Che Guevara.
Oh, absolutely.
When you think Che today, you
almost inevitably think of that
image, right The court of.
Photo It's everywhere.
T-shirts, posters, mugs.
But the actual Che, the man
himself, yeah, was about as far
from a harmless fashion
statement as you could get.
Totally.
The real Che was a hardcore
Marxist revolutionary, a
guerrilla commander, ruthless,
disciplined, sometimes brutal.
Executing traitors, Waging
insurgencies.
Yeah, trying to export
revolution across Latin America,
Africa.
He believed in armed struggle,
violence to overthrow systems he
saw as oppressive.
He was driven, committed and, by
conventional standards, extreme.
Definitely not cute, not
fashionable on the way his image
is used now.
Not at all, but look what
happened after he was killed.
His image got completely
detached from who he was and
what he did it.
Became a commodity.
The ultimate example of
deburring through
commodification.
That famous photo is everywhere,
but it's almost completely
disconnected from his ideology,
his actions, the violence.
And the irony, as the sources
say, is just staggering.
These things are sold in the
same malls he would have burned
down.
Or at least the capitalist
system those malls represent,
who she fought violently to
destroy.
So the T-shirt Che isn't
dangerous anymore.
He's just a symbol.
A symbol of what though?
They'd rebellion.
Anti establishment?
Cool.
It's usually pretty unclear.
Just a look.
Yeah.
A prop, A fashion accessory.
The actual revolutionary Che,
the one who believed in armed
struggle and communism, is
basically gone from that image.
The mascot is what's left.
And this commodification angle
is really key, isn't it?
It is because it shows how the
system can just eat its enemies.
It absorbs even the most radical
symbols, turns them into
products, and in doing so,
strips them of their original
power.
The revolution gets sold back
to.
You right and once it's just
another product you can buy,
it's not a threat anymore it
actually becomes part of the
consumer system in a pose and
shows how incredibly resilient
and adaptive that system is and
this.
Deburring.
It's not just political figures.
It happens in religion too.
Think about Saint Francis of
Assisi.
Yeah, the Birdbath St.
Exactly.
Gentle guy talking to animals
maybe started the Christmas
nativity scene.
That's the image, right?
Nature kindness.
That's the de bird Francis, the
real Francis.
Back in the 12th, 13th
centuries, he was radical.
He founded an order based on
absolute radical poverty.
They begged for food, own
nothing.
He openly challenged the
Church's wealth and power,
demanded total commitment to the
Gospel ideals of poverty,
humility.
So he was a troublemaker for the
church establishment.
Oh yeah, The sources say his
movement terrified the church
establishment because it
reminded them too much of the
Gospels.
Think about that.
His faithfulness was a threat.
He wasn't just pious, he was a
living critique of the
institution.
A revolutionary within the
Church.
Absolutely.
But the image we have now, the
gentle guy with the birds, it's
safe, sentimental, domesticated.
It focuses on the animals, not
the radical poverty or the
challenge to wealth.
Exactly.
The dangerous part, the part
that might make us question our
wealth or the church's wealth
today, gets erased.
The institution and popular
culture sort of rebranded him,
softened him.
Sold him back as a spiritual
Santa Claus, as one source puts
it.
A comforting figure, not a
demanding 1.
The radical call is replaced by
a gentle, harmless icon.
And this isn't just ancient
history.
It seems like it happens with
contemporary figures to Pope
Francis, for example.
Right.
The perception, especially
outside the Church, is often the
liberal Pope.
The Who am I to judge Pope?
Seems like a big shift.
Very open, Merciful.
And his persona definitely
projects that he uses modern
media well, speaks excessively,
makes gestures of humility.
It's a very different style, but
the sources we looked at
emphasize you have to look past
the the brand on core issues.
Nothing has shifted in Catholic
doctrine.
So sacraments are still
sacraments.
Marriage is still defined the
same way.
Exactly.
Blessings for same sex couples
were allowed, but explicitly
stated not to be.
Marriage inclusion is
emphasized, but the underlying
rules, the doctrine, haven't
fundamentally changed.
So it's more about presentation,
a softer face.
That's the argument.
He's the smiling face of
continuity.
Excellent brand management for
the church in the 21st century.
One source called it a steel
spine wrapped in velvet.
Steel spine wrapped in velvet.
Wow.
Projecting mercy and openness,
but without actually altering
the core positions on many
controversial things.
Why does this matter in a
spiritual context?
Well, it shows that even
institutions of faith engage in
this branding, this potential
deburring.
It allows norms to persist while
projecting an image of change.
Which might make it harder to
challenge things from inside or
outside.
Possibly, if the perception is
already 1 of openness and
progress, it can kind of diffuse
calls for more fundamental
shifts.
It shows that institutions can
adapt their image quite
effectively without necessarily
changing their core substance.
What's really hitting me is how
widespread this is.
It's not just famous leaders.
It's everywhere in culture.
Totally pervasive.
You see it all the time once you
start looking.
Music is a great example.
Like punk rock?
Yeah started raw anti
establishment DIY angry.
Really threatening to some
people.
Absolutely.
Then over time, what happens?
It gets absorbed.
It becomes mall punk.
Polished commercial sold in
chain stores.
Right.
The look might be there, maybe
some of the attitude, but the
real threat, the genuine
rejection of the system, mostly
gone neutralized.
Where the hippies back in the
60s?
That was a huge counterculture
movement rejecting materialism,
war, conformity.
Whole different way of thinking
about life and society.
Communal living, questioning
authority.
Now you buy tie dye T-shirts at
Target.
Eace signs are just decoration.
The radical philosophy gets
stripped away and you're left
with basically an aesthetic, a
style that can be bought and
sold.
Within the very system it tried
to reject.
Exactly.
And even newer movements like
think about radical feminism,
deep critiques of patriarchy,
power structures calling for
fundamental change.
Then that gets turned into.
Sometimes it gets watered down
into things like girl boss
culture, right, Which is more
about individual women
succeeding within the existing
corporate system, not
challenging the system itself.
Personal empowerment over
systemic change.
Right.
It takes the edge off, makes it
marketable maybe, but loses the
radical critique.
It really is like the system
doesn't just fight its enemies,
it digests them.
It eats them, digests them, and
spits them back out as safe
consumer products.
That metaphor from the source
material is so powerful.
It's unsettling, like an immune
system response, but for
culture.
It really is, and the goal seems
clear.
Once you're on the poster, once
you're a slogan, once you're a
brand, you're not really a
threat anymore.
You're managed.
It's a survival mechanism for
the dominant system.
Neutralize challenges by
absorbing them, making them part
of the scenery, part of the
market.
It's control, but it often looks
like celebration.
Which brings us, I suppose, to
the biggest example of all, the
one that's been going on the
longest.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah, when we think of Jesus
today, the images are often so
gentle.
The baby in the Manger, the
shepherd, the kind teacher.
But historically, the context,
he was executed by Rome.
As a political threat.
As a political threat, he talked
about a Kingdom that wasn't
Caesar's that overturned power
structures.
He challenged the religious
authorities, the economic system
in the temple.
His followers were seen as a
disruptive movement.
He wasn't passive.
That story about whipping the
money changers out of the
temple, that's pretty
confrontational.
It's direct action against
economic exploitation within a
sacred space and the cross
itself.
We see it as jewelry now, or a
symbol of faith.
But originally.
Originally it was a brutal tool
of state terror, Roman execution
for rebels, slaves, enemies of
the state, designed to inflict
maximum pain and humiliation as
a public warning.
So he was seen as dangerous.
Arguably, as the sources put it,
the most dangerous revolutionary
of his time, threatening Roman
power, threatening the local
religious elite.
His very message challenged the
foundations of that world.
And yet, look at the
transformation 2000 years later.
He's become the mascot of
Christmas, sentimentalized,
associated with gifts, family
dinners, goodwill.
The Baby Jesus.
A comforting story for kids.
The radical challenge to power,
wealth, empire.
Where did it go?
Got deburred over centuries,
sanded down, rebranded,
commodified the cross.
Becomes a necklace.
Exactly.
It's two millennia of smoothing
out the edges.
Early Christians were
persecuted, Then the religion
adapted, became dominant, and in
that process the figure of Jesus
was also reshaped, made less
disruptive to earthly powers
perhaps.
Until he becomes, as the source
says, the ultimate Santa Claus
figure.
Safe, palatable for everyone.
You can put them on a Christmas
card in the mall without anyone
thinking about overthrowing
empires or giving all their
possessions to the poor.
The absorption is total.
It really highlights how
powerful and long term this
process can be, how even the
most radical origins can be
completely transformed,
domesticated, made to serve
purposes utterly different from
the original.
It shows hegemony isn't just
about short term control, it's
about shaping memory and meaning
over vast stretches of time.
So wrapping this up, the core
idea we've explored today is
really that hegemony dominant
power often survives not by
destroying the revolutionary,
but by taming them.
Domesticating.
Them.
Yeah.
It grinds them down, deburs the
edge, polishes the dangerous
tool until it's safe to hold.
It's a process.
And then the system takes that
polished fish and brands them,
turns them into an icon for
values the system can handle.
Right.
King becomes a dreamer.
Not the radical critic Malcolm
X, the truth teller, but less
the militant.
Yeah.
The T-shirt Rebel Francis The
Bird Loving Garden St.
And Jesus, the baby and the
Manger, Yeah.
The dangerous ones are gone.
The Santa Clauses are what's
left.
So the thought we want to leave
you with as you go about your
week, just take a moment, look
around at the figures, the
ideas, the movements presented
to you.
Ask yourself, is there anything
being deburred right now?
Any sharp edges being smoothed
out?
What might we be losing when we
accept the easy, comfortable
version of a person or an idea?
What's the specific edge, the
uncomfortable bit?
The challenging part that's
maybe being missed or
deliberately hidden?
Because it's happening all the
time, often right under our
noses, and just recognizing it,
seeing the process is maybe the
first step to really thinking
critically about the world we
live in.